So a person said in a list of this is what I asked a lot of you to do so many times you are taking
When you guys start with me, you're taking a bunch of different supplements
So this is an example of a person that's taking a bunch of different supplements that none of this is ours, right?
so
And when I do the testing, I may say, okay
I may go, okay, this is
Let's pretend that that's let's say
Seac didn't test well at all, and I'll just say stop so I'll say stop this stop this stop this and all of you
Know what I'm talking about because I did this when I did your original test eat
There's things that you're taking that I told you to stop taking and then there's things that I said
Well, you can keep taking that as long as if you want and and sometimes I told you and you can keep taking if you run out
Then let me know and many times you many of you have let me know when you do run out of saying so I can say
Oh, you don't need that anymore. It was nothing wrong with you taking it
But now that you're out don't keep taking it. I don't want you guys taking 500 different supplements. So
So just make sure let's say if you're it's even better if you're like a week away
I have one week left
Let's say I didn't tell you to take the SCAC, but you felt led to take the XSEAC to make sure you be able to have one week left
of the SCAC and the baby we should set up a time to talk about whether you should keep taking that or not
so
but
Because we're testing your cheek swab and you're taking all this stuff. We're testing you when you're taking that stuff. So
I only take you off things that I think that are bad for you that are poor
Orally-key-lated minerals or supplements with methyl groups that you know, there's there's other reasons why I may take you off something